my observations indicated you get
durable regulation that will stick
around so long as the Baptist and the
bootleggers have a common objective
I'm Bruce Yandel quite active in
lecturing writing associated with the
Mercatus Center at George Mason
University now giving lectures working
with students doing a lot of the same
stuff I've done for many many years in
the public policy arena the idea of of
the bootleggers baptist theory developed
in my mind about 1982 I was the
executive director of the Federal Trade
Commission for a couple of years and I
was there in Washington at that time
attempting to explain regulations the
nature of regulations and the kind of
support that we see that brings
regulation forward and it occurred to me
well the old story about bootleggers and
Baptists seems to apply here
both bootleggers and Baptists like to
see the liquor stores closed on Sunday
the bootleggers like to buy their booze
on Saturday so they want the liquor
stores open on Saturday but they want
them closed on Sunday that gives them an
open market to sell their product
usually at pretty high prices the
Baptist's won't the liquor stores closed
on Sunday just one day a week relief
from demon rum but when it comes to
getting support to maintain those
statutes in place you will never see
bootleggers with a placard in front of a
state capitol saying help support your
local bootlegger they don't have to
lobby the Baptist's do it for them and
the Baptist's make certain that the law
is enforced and so you have a Baptist
enforced cartel that provides wealth for
the bootleggers happiness for the
Baptist's and when you have a coalition
like that my observations indicated you
get durable regulation that will stick
around so long as the Baptist and the
bootleggers have a common objective
most of those are showing up now in the
area of climate change for example you
have environmental organizations who are
members of coalition's joined by some
energy companies that are primarily
nuclear in their sources of energy or
natural gas
both those bootleggers and Baptists
won't to get restrictions on carbon
emissions so clean energy producers are
very visible walking hand-in-hand with
environmental organizations and one
other group brokerage firms so that if
we get cap-and-trade legislation the
brokerage firms will be the one who will
be managing the sale of those new
permits and certificates so we do see
visible coalition's now it's also
showing up across Europe with respect to
what is called echo labeling
requirements of that all products
consumer products be labeled as to their
environmental impact and so the echo
labels are being pushed by environmental
groups and also producers of products
who will be able to keep out competitors
and competitive entry from other firms
and some are modifying how they produce
their product in order to get a good
label that may be desirable from the
environmentalist standpoint it's very
difficult for some other producers to
meet those standards so we we see that
going on I guess the most recent one
that it's truly interesting in a way
because it sort of goes back to the
origins of the bootleggers baptist
characters it's what we see with
initiatives of California initiatives
that will be coming up in November for
example with respect to the legalization
of the sale of marijuana and the
legislation of course includes in the
title legalizing and taxing marijuana
and and there we see you know
fascinating things
I guess not not visibly named but
obvious as to who they are producers of
pot in Humboldt County California who
are putting out bumper stickers saying
keep pot illegal hoping that they will
hold on to their bootleggers territory
just in the traditional sense of the
word and what is not as clear in this
case though are the Baptist where are
they they're not making the kinds of
noises that they might have in the past
and those would be those who might be in
the pulpit saying we've got to keep this
illegal and controlled one of the things
that we learn from the study of
bootleggers and Baptists is that when
the Baptist's go away the bootleggers
lose their territory
it requires that it's for the regulation
for the institution to stay in place
both parties have to be very active as
they play some people believe I don't
know the data but some people certainly
believe that in Humboldt County and in
other locations where pot is being grown
illegally that this stimulates the local
economy just as any other economic
activity would and so you have local
merchants operators of grocery stores
people selling gasoline people running
restaurants saying hey this is part of
our economy and if this thing goes
competitive then they know the price
fetched in the marketplace is going to
decline it's going to be harmful and
then some people say heaven forbid the
large tobacco companies may be coming
into this market and the next thing you
know the local producers will just be no
more yeah and an interesting story about
the the Humboldt County situation there
was a really neat statement by someone
that said if you really want to support
farmers in America make wheat illegal so
that the price will go up so that you do
have local communities here saying hey
this is part of our economy
California is running an estimated
20 billion dollar deficit as that's the
current estimate and by some counts that
those tax revenues could reach as much
as 1.4 billion dollars annually and now
there are a lot of assumptions that go
into that statement but there always are
but the point is the same you have a
state hard-pressed to maintain the
services that everyone wants and some
which people would call essential and
they're looking for revenue and so this
may be a tab this may be one of those
watershed moments when lurking back in
the background is economic necessity and
maybe a fracturing of the bootlegger
Baptist coalition's so if I had to place
a bit I would bet that that initiative
is going to pass